ماذا يحدث في الخرطوم المعظم قال لا اريد
ان اتذكر البعض قال الخرطوم انتهت معظم
المواطنين السودانيين ايضا الذين تم
اجلاؤهم خاصه يوم امس من كبار السن قال
يعني ما زلنا في امل ان يعود السودان بخير
الجنسيات الاخرى بعضهم تعرضوا لاطلاق نار
فمثلا
السيد الذي امامنا وهو يحمل الجنسيه
الفلسطينيه كنا نحاول ان نتحدث معه
ونحاولوا لكن الرفض التعليق ولكن لعل هذه
المره الثانيه الذي احاول ان اسالك كيف هو
الوضع في السودان
والله يا اخي الكريم الوضع مزري والله
يعين الناس
شاهدته كنت تقص علي على حديث جانبي نريد
ان المشاهد يسمع
يعني عندك المعلومات كلها انه كان في
مقدمات الازمه والعائله الكلام بعدين فجاه
انفجر الوضع
والناس والله تعبانه جدا جدا
شكرا لك شكرا اذا ما زال يخفي الكثير
السيد محمد هو من من الاشخاص الذين كانوا
يزوروا السودان في فتره طويله
انفصلوا عن انفصلت عائلته عن
نجا بنفسه وتبقى بعض ابنائي هناك لا يعلم
عنهم
البعض الاخر هو وصل الى جده بامان ما زال
هو قلق ولكن كان يتحدث اليه عن مشاهدته
للرصاص المنطقه التي كان يقطن فيها في
السودان منطقه خطيره جدا لم يستطيع الخروج
ظل قرابه سبعه ايام او اربعه ايام في
منزله لم يستطع الخروج منها الا بواسطه
التدخل احد اعضاء القنصليه الماليزيه هناك
فخرج سالما واليوم وصل الى جده هذا هو
حديثه طبعا هو رفض تماما حاولت ان يتحدث
معه بشكل اكثر على الشاشه
ولكن كانوا يرفض
الامر كان يسير قبل قليل وتحدث الينا
بكلمتين ولكن هذا هو الحال معظم الذين
وصلوا لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات